[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos sobre la conmemoración del
bicentenario de la muerte de napoleón
bonaparte el legado del ex militar
francés y emperador sigue siendo
polémico juan carlos henao rector de la
universidad externado de colombia nos
acompañó más temprano para hablar sobre
el legado en la región que dejó el
emperador y le preguntamos cuál fue la
repercusión de la invasión de napoleón a
españa para las independencias
latinoamericanas
la invasión de napoleón en 1804 a españa
fue muy importante para mí américa
latina' por varios motivos
digamos que uno primero fue que al
producirse la vacancia real cierto de la
monarquía española porque napoleón
nombra a su hermano pepe botellas como
emperador de españa entonces al
producirse esa vacancia de fernando
séptimo
si se forman unos gobiernos en contra de
la invasión invasión napoleónica en
contra la invasión napoleónica de otros
gobiernos en contra empiezan a tener
muchas relaciones con la gente aquí en
colombia y en general en américa latina
donde ya de por sí el ambiente está bien
caldeado sí bien caldeado por la
revolución en francesa por la revolución
americana entonces en esas juntas que se
forman y empiezan a tener relación con
los criollos que se llaman que eran los
nativos de américa latina se va
generando como una especie también de
rebeldía en contra de la de la de la
corona española porque lo que después
fue la constitución de cádiz
y los gobiernos que fueron un poco en
contra de napoleón convocaron a unas
juntas en américa latina pero esa junta
las convocaron de una manera digamos muy
discriminatoria porque de cuatro que
habían uno solamente era el criollo y
los otros lo eran de españa eso generó
por ejemplo en memoria
el día agravio de camino torre de 1809
que es un es uno de los actos más
importantes precursores de la libertad
de la libertad de españa porque porque
allí a raíz de eso se empieza a sentir
maltratada la gente aquí en colombia y
es donde se desencadena la revolución
independentista que guía simón bolívar
preguntamos también cuál es el legado
más grande que dejó napoleone en los
actuales estados de américa latina
yo diría que el legado más grande de
napoleón es el llamado código de
napoleón el código civil de napoleón que
fue traducido por don andrés bello ese
código civiles de 1804 y realmente lo
dijo chirac cuando se cumplieron los 200
años del código civil de napoleón que
había sido el mejor envase embajador de
la cultura jurídica francesa lo cual no
cabe la menor duda porque este este
código civil que estaban por portal y
cierto y que lo hicieron bajo napoleón
por eso se llama así este código
repercutió completamente en todos los
países de américa latina hay similitudes
entre la figura de napoleón y la de
simón bolívar
digamos que yo creo que hay muchas
similitudes entre simón bolívar y
napoleón la primera es que en esa época
a inicios del siglo pase del siglo 19 la
figura de lo militar era muy importante
y era muy importante porque las
revoluciones se hacían por intermedio de
los militares y tanto napoleón como
bolívar eran militares y allí había
digamos una una unión que napoleón
siempre fue una referencia aparecimos
bolívar simón bolívar le tenía mucho
respeto a napoleón y digamos que en otro
punto en que tristemente también fueron
muy similares es que a partir de un
discurso muy liberal muy propio de la
revolución francesa terminaron siendo
unas personas que traicionaron sus
principios en colombia también se trató
de colocar una monarquía hereditaria y
realmente bolívar al igual que napoleón
terminaron siendo unos dictadores
finalmente la figura de napoleón es
polémica algunos lo idolatran y otros
solo detestan como la considera usted
no claro que la figura de napoleón pues
si hay mucha gente que lo admira pero
personalmente yo considero que él
terminó siendo un dictador y como
dictador pues lo demócrata no estamos de
acuerdo y aún más consideró que él
terminó traicionando los postulados de
la revolución francesa sí
hasta aquí en cinco minutos consiga con
nosotros en france 24 y france24
puntocom buenos días
[Música]